[Music]
hello there October is here again
historically the month which brings the
biggest games of the Year this is the
series in which we highlight the games
worth your time from the full price to
the totally free to play so there's
something for everyone and this October
is packed a big thank you to focus
entertainment for sponsoring this video
and we'll be looking at their latest
game hard space shipbreaker a little
later in the video you ready let's do
this
arguably the biggest game of the month
is Gotham Knights a Batman game without
a Batman inspired by the comic book run
making Robin Nightwing red hood and
Batgirl step out of the Dark Knight
Shadow and into the Limelight following
his demise Gotham Knight combat takes
its inspiration from the Arkham series
with each hero having unique moves to
utilize we're told Batgirl has the
closest to the Arkham games with other
characters like red hood having more mid
to long range attacks hopefully making
each hero feel completely different this
version of Gotham is the last largest
ever created in a video game and
includes citizens going about their
daily business there'll be five areas to
patrol while a bigger mystery regarding
the court of owls unfolds and if you're
wondering about the augmented reality
detective missions they are here for you
Batman purists whether on foot in the
air or in vehicles we'll face super
villains constantly already confirmed
are Harley Quinn Clayface penguin and Mr
Freeze with more to be revealed and
found Gotham Knight's releases on
October 21st on PS5 Xbox series and PC
sadly last gen is not supported
an unexpected game suddenly revealed
itself new Tales from the Borderlands
I'm sure you remember the days of
Telltale Games and the interactive story
genre they grew almost eight years later
we have a new story to follow with a new
band of Misfit Heroes these games
historically don't have a lot of
gameplay in them as everything is about
progressing the story instead we choose
the direction of the narrative it most
definitely is not a first person shooter
like the mainline games set about one
year after the events of Borderlands 3
we travel to Promethea as they rebuild
their homes the weapon manufacturers TDR
and Atlas have seen this as an
opportunity to take control of the
planet and find themselves in direct
opposition we've been told to expect
characters from previous games to pop up
along our journey and will uncover New
pieces of lore in the Borderlands
Universe new Tales is not a full price
game either retailing at 40.40 Euros or
35 quid for commoners like me October
21st if you are interested on
Playstation Xbox switch and PC
next hard space shipbreaker I've teamed
up with Focus entertainment to show you
the daily life of a spaceship salvager I
was trying to find the best way to
describe this game quickly and I think I
have it imagine if no man's sky and
subnautica had a baby through a story
driven campaign we must pay off our
debts by dismantling decommissioned
spaceships for their valuable items the
better the job we do the more profit we
make and more of our debt we pay off oh
and if we somehow don't survive don't
worry a new clone will be created from
your DNA and that's another debt you
have to pay off once the zero g Basics
are mastered the missions become
increasingly more varied and challenging
from preventing explosions to battling
Rogue AI to intricate laser cutting
valuable material which will blow up the
entire ship if done incorrectly hard
space shipbreaker released on PC earlier
this year and sits at an 89 approval
rating and now it's on Console too right
now if that sounds like your kind of
game name there's a link in the
description
[Music]
okay on to the free game section and
holy heck what a selection we have the
most eye-catching is OverWatch 2 which
will be a totally free to play game from
the date releases unlike the original
which took over the world back in 2016.
the game has been overhauled but
essentially it's a typical hero shooter
with bags of Personality thanks to a
roster of over 30 characters all with
their own unique moves abilities and
play Styles the PVP the player versus
player team mode is now 5 on 5 which is
one character less than the six on six
in the OG game and the reason why I keep
bringing up OverWatch 1 is because those
servers will be shut down forever when
OverWatch 2 takes over we've been
promised game updates every nine weeks
which will all be paid for Via a battle
pass which will be themed differently
each season and just like fortnite there
is a free tier for those who don't want
to pay the future of OverWatch looks
very interesting as in 2023 new PVE
content will be coming you'll no longer
have to play against Real opponents if
you prefer for storage content OverWatch
2 lands on October 4th on Playstation
Xbox PC and switch and if you're
wondering progression from all platforms
is maintained cross progression
confirmed
one of the greatest social simulators of
all time is going free to play in
October the Sims 4. from creating your
own home to decking it out with all the
mod cons you want building a life having
kids then sending them off to University
or in my case removing the ladder from
the swimming pool and watching them
slowly lose their mind play it your way
I won't judge you you don't judge me the
Sims 4 has been updated hundreds of
times over the years from quality of
life improvements to full DLC upgrades
and to be completely transparent the
only three part confirmed is the base
game some of those DLCs have been
integrated but the plan is for us to buy
those expansions oh and if you already
own Sims 4 there's a free gift coming
your way the Sims 4 goes free to play on
all platforms on October 18th will you
jump into the live simulator and learn a
little simlish susum or phoebele zawalco
Geneva sorry about that
but wait there's another free game in
October a brand new one too take a look
at death verse let it die a survival
Battle Royale that rejects the
kid-friendly approach and goes for
something a little more edgy we are
thrown into a game show named death
Jamboree and we are watched by millions
of Spectators as we fight to be the only
Survivor of a game of life and death
weapon upgrades have been spotted in
trailers and show-stopping moves to
appeal to the audience too but
surprisingly there is a limited amount
of official info about death verse
online and it releases very soon if
you're watching this on the day the
video comes out it's in two days on
PlayStation 5 and Playstation 4 on
September 28th followed by PC via Steam
on October 5th is this just another
battle royale clone or will it be a real
Contender next back to full priced games
and the shooter Juggernaut Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 2 it arrives on October
28th a continuation of the reboot from
2019 follows SAS Captain John price as
he builds Task Force 1 4 1 an elite
counter-terrorism unit in my opinion the
story of the first game was amazing but
the real calling card of Call of Duty is
the great shooting mechanics and they
are here and perfect as always the
multiplayer beta is going on while I'm
saying this and as usual the community
either loves it or absolutely hates it
it's most likely the real test will be
when the free-to-play was on two
releases in November personally I'm
buying Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 for
the story I want to see what happens to
ghost this time MW2 releases on October
28th on Playstation Xbox and PC
back in 2019 a hugely underrated game
released plague tale innocence two
siblings attempt to outrun a disease
spread by rats in medieval France and
now plague tale Requiem is here Hands-On
previews have given us a real insight to
story and mechanics after Hugo's powers
to control rats were uncovered in the
first game it's now clear he has a
greater understanding of his abilities
and can use those swarms of rats to
attack his enemies and to solve puzzles
too a really ingenious key mechanic is
the overuse of his ability which causes
Hugo to faint and a sea of rats to
envelop everything putting their lives
at risk plagetail Requiem releases on
October 18th on PS5 Xbox series and PC
and also on Twitch via the cloud and
finally a very different type of game
Dragon Ball the breakers a super cheap
20 game this is Dragon Ball's attempt at
asymmetrical gameplay just like dead by
daylight seven Ordinary People are
trapped in a temporal phenomenon and
must escape the thing is another entity
from another timeline is there too
hunting them down the survivors work
together to defeat the Raider and or
Escape before being eliminated the
Raider has a superior moveset but the
survivors have numbers on their side as
usual it's absolutely great playing as
the Raider but it takes a solid group of
survivors to cooperate for a change from
the typical Dragon Ball games that
release the breakers is a breath of
fresh air and people who liked Friday
the 13th the game but found it a bit too
nerve-wracking now have a less stressful
time Dragon Ball the breakers drops on
October 14th on Playstation Xbox switch
and PC so there we have it what do you
think of this month there is so much to
choose from what you're playing I'm Adam
you're awesome and so are Focus
entertainment for sponsoring this video
thank you kindly I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]